last week swag signed with a new org and
it's not just the same old [ __ ] guys
on the roster anymore
it's a roster that might actually be
able to do something
but you know what that's not even the
point because i've been waiting for
years
to tell you what swag really brings to
the table for an org that has the guts
to sign him
and i'm not just talking about what he
does in the server
[Music]
so last week your boy braxton swag
pierce signed with an esports org called
lazarus
they're new on the scene they used to be
called stdx a bit of an unfortunate name
not really the point canadian org though
shout outs to canada
now i don't know how this new org is
gonna handle this team of n a players
but i've been wanting to talk about swag
in particular
now in case you've been living under a
rock for the last i don't know four or
five years
obviously he's one of the players that
was involved in the i buy power match
fixing scandal he got banned uh
indefinitely aka for life from
any valve sponsored cs go event so this
once great figure has been forced to
toil in the lower levels
of cs go for a number of years and none
of that has changed he's still banned
but there's something special about swag
in particular
i know it and you know it more so than
the other players that got banned via
that i buy power scandal
there's a mythology that surrounds this
young man
he's like robin hood he's borderline
legendary status because
he got banned because in his young days
in sort of the prime of his career or
right before the apex of his career he
was cut down he was taken away from us
by valve or by deciding to match fix
whatever you want
that's not the point of this video the
point is we
lost swag we never saw him fulfill his
full potential
and thus it created this aura around him
that he was like a
magical mythical figure and everyone
likes to talk about what ifs
oh what if swag was unbanned what if he
never got banned in the first place
would cloud9 have won a major before
they did in boston would that specific
i buy power team go on to foster a new n
a
scene did we get set back in n a
competitive cs go
so many years because of that big ban
well these are the questions that
surround this player and these are the
things that help build up his mythology
and that mystique is where swag's value
comes from now don't get me wrong he's a
great player he can still do incredible
things
but personally and you can flame me in
the comments for this one i don't think
at present time in 2019 he can hang with
the best of the best i don't think he's
going to win a 1v1 against simple
i don't necessarily think he's an
astralis killer but he is
a great player the problem thus far is
that being a great player has not been
enough
to counterbalance the fact that he
cannot attend valve events
you cannot make a major with swag on
your roster so of course orgs have
stayed away from signing him
but here's where i would argue that's a
mistake success
in esports success in cs go is
more than just winning yes winning is a
huge part of it
yes winning is still the best way to win
fans to get
brand cachet in any esport especially cs
go but it's not the entire piece of the
pie
especially in 2019 you got to put butts
in seats so to speak
you got to get youtube views you gotta
sell jerseys and you need to attract
sponsors the best way to do those things
is winning
but guess what not everyone can win
that's just how math works not every
team
can win a major not every team can make
a major look at this last one in iem
katowice
we had great teams that didn't even get
to go to poland
shout out to mousesports so if teams in
the top 10 hltv rankings aren't
necessarily guaranteed a spot in the
major
what good are teams at the bottom of
that top 20 or god forbid
outside of that top 20 what are they
gonna do now
no org is ever gonna admit to you maybe
even to themselves
that they're not gonna make the major
and every team should be built to win of
course
i'm not arguing for a pure publicity
stunt move here
but the fact of the matter is swag is a
good player he brings
a presence in the server but so much
more the mythology
the mystique the fandom you put his name
on the back of your jersey
you will sell those jerseys you get
people talking about him
you get him to tournaments sponsors will
take notice
money will come you put him together
with four
great players this is what's going to
happen you're going to start winning
or at least competing every esports org
including a counter-strike is obsessed
with the idea
of winning winning winning and they
should be it's a competitive endeavor
but the best ones realize that's not the
only way to get fans to get
sponsorships to get money coming in and
butts in the seats
so you can't have your entire brand
value
be predicated on one concept and again
this is why swag is so valuable and if
you think this isn't a real worry
just look at all the cs go orgs that
have pulled out come back in
pulled out again in the last say two
years i mean dignitas clg
rogue was like two weeks ago and those
are only some of the bigger names
there's been tons of smaller orgs that
have tried to make a go
in this very cutthroat esport they
haven't cracked the top 20 top 10 of
hltv's rankings
and they've disappeared that's the
reality it's an expensive
endeavor hell even sk gaming has talked
to us personally about the trouble
that they've had when it comes to
sponsorships in cs go so every little
bit helps we did make an entire video on
that by the way so you should probably
check that out too so just to be
absolutely crystal clear here guys i am
not saying that you can sit at the
bottom of the proverbial tables
sign swag and make that cash that's just
not how it's going to work
it's got to be winning and it has to be
personality
brand cachet as well it actually reminds
me a lot of something ocelot told us
when we interviewed him on our podcast
earlier this year if you follow g2
may that be as a hater as a lover you
know you will be entertained you know
that you know that right you will watch
our games
you know you'll be interesting it
doesn't matter what game you look at we
are always top two
worldwide or top three maybe worldwide
in terms of viewership
numbers any game you look at and which
as a result provide a very good
kind of league revenue sharing whatever
league we're a part of hell some of you
guys have been following us for a while
probably know i'm a phase clan fan and
well um they haven't won anything in a
little while in cs go
but you gotta love them because the
branding is on point the personalities
are there
and yeah they're great players too so
that's what i'm talking about
the synergy between performance and
branding if you don't believe me
just flashback two years ago when cloud9
subbed in swag for summit
it was just summit but no one would shut
up about it
it was like the most exciting thing in
cs for six months
oh what shut up swag now if you're still
watching this video and you still
haven't typed a comment in pure rage
saying but colin
won't sign swag because he's not
unpainted in foul majors or everything
to that i say how about this how about
an org
goes out gets swag they put them
together with four
great players with obviously some
synergistic team play in mind and they
just mindlessly pick up the
top 10 players they can find right they
put together a good team
with swag on it people start talking
they start going to events
dream hacks e-leagues esl stuff
they start winning a few of them or at
least placing competitively
i think they're gonna have such a ground
swell of fan support people like you and
me
saying this team is amazing you got to
let them play that valve
will actually amend their rules and let
them into a minor
and then potentially open the door to a
major you might say it's crazy i know
valve has a track record
of not bending when it comes to this
kind of stuff but if there is a strong
enough community movement a strong
enough
grassroots push i think it could
actually happen i've been waiting for
years for an organization with a the
foresight
and be the guts to go ahead and do this
and show us what's really possible free
swag
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you